[Música]
porque conoce segundo invitaba el día
vamos a hablar de como vacacionar este
verano este año 2022 con un dólar en
nuestros países de américa latina y el
caribe tan alto también cómo se
comportan nuestras sociedades
latinoamericanas con una inflación tan
alta pues me acompañan de representar a
nuestro segundo invitado al día por
supuesto nuestra encargada de economía
de todas las mañanas daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida nuevamente y ahora si
dan y entonces le damos la bienvenida a
arturo farías académico investigador de
la facultad de administración economía
de la universidad tecnológica
metropolitana de chile arturo muy buen
día gracias por estar esta mañana de
miércoles con nosotros aquí en directo
américa de france 24
buen día
la invitación arturo pues la pregunta
del millón no sobre todo nosotros que
vivimos aquí en américa latina y el
caribe con esta hiperinflación en muchos
países con un dólar más imparable por
todo él pues el acontecimiento mundial
vacacionamos nos vacacionamos y si
decidimos vacacionar pues cuáles son
digamos las recomendaciones para no
llegar con un desfalco digamos económico
nuestro bolsillo
condiciones hoy día en general en todo
lo que es latinoamérica ha sido bien
compleja situación que nos había dado
anteriormente obviamente un producto de
los últimos acontecimientos la pandemia
y que ha provocado este este ajuste
económico en toda latinoamérica y en
nuestro principal
ente que eeuu de la boca y parte todo un
tema complejo del punto vista económico
normalmente cuando se presentan estos
temas de alza del dólar el turismo tenía
ciertos beneficios sobre todo en
aquellos países en los cuales esta
moneda se estaba depreciando por la toga
la tigra en tu familia es conveniente
poder visitar esos países porque tus
dudas se van aumentando aumentando de
nuevo la tontería de mayor capacidad
lamentablemente hoy día
esta alza realizada el dólar
complicado dicha situación pero nosotros
sabemos que bajo ese esquema hoy día hay
principalmente tres países que son los
que están bien complejos en ese sentido
como son argentinas en primer lugar
chile y colombia que son los tres países
que han sufrido de mayor manera este
alza del dólar y la depreciación de sus
monedas por lo tanto para nosotros y
cualquier persona que quiera efectuar
ese ese día es que soy acierto de
vacaciones estos otros países
dependiendo de las características que
tiene su manera local enfrentando las
tendría que evaluarlo a evaluarlo muy
bien ya
un diario que también tenemos países que
no han tenido como estos tres países
este este grado de afección tan grande
por ejemplo brasil por ejemplo méxico
por ejemplo perú y nuestro vecino
uruguay que a diferencia de muchos otros
uruguay su moneda se ha apreciado frente
al dólar entonces es un tema bien bien
relevante pero tiene algún aspecto que
es el tema de la inflación ya que es
importantísimo puesto que los valores
esta inflación que también ha sido
generalizada a lo largo de latinoamérica
también hace que los precios internos de
dichos países aumenten entonces antes
podría jugar todo conversando que el
alza del dólar podría provocar
beneficios ciento para ciertos países lo
cual esta moneda se deprecie pero
también olviden que poner mucho ojo con
respecto a cuál es el nivel de precios
al interior del país entonces eso
también complica un poco la decisión
de
los países en general si el señor
arturo señor arturo yo a la pregunta que
siempre me enfrentó por parte pues de la
gente de mis familiares conocidos que
van a viajar es que es lo más
recomendable comprar dólares cuando el
dólar está tan dólares en el país de
origen de uno y llevarlos y cambiarlos
en esos otros países o llevar el peso de
una vez yo sé que depende de cada país
pero tenemos una situación casi que un
común denominador en varios países como
cómo tomar esa decisión al momento de
comprar pesos o comprar la moneda local
o comprar dólares
en estos momentos comenzó esta alza
generalizada en diferentes países hace
que quizás esa decisión que era muy
común cuando por efecto del eje
decidirlo enviada a la situación que se
presenta ya no es han decidido algo que
tuvo un día en comparación con el país
donde tú quieras viajar
compartida con el país donde quiera
fijar si tú todavía está mucho más con
posicionada al país donde quiere dejar
te conviene comprar dólares en tu país y
por cierto aplicarlo en dicho país si la
comunidad de la situación de ambos
países es muy similar digamos la
diferencia entre uno y otro invierno es
tan relevante estos signos del turista y
nosotros si queremos estar media tengo
que hacer una pequeña comparación que
conozcan mi situación con respecto a la
situación al lugar que quiero viajar con
tenencia a otros países en la práctica
que por ejemplo en brasil no se ha
devaluado su moneda entonces su moneda
entonces si yo estoy en brasil y quiero
viajar por ejemplo a colombia también
compraron brasil mis dólares
luego
de efectuar ese proceso en señor arturo
y también ahí tenemos una otra situación
en el mundo ella es la paridad del euro
con el dólar ha disminuido un poquito
perdón ha aumentado un poquito la brecha
pero están casi que igual el dólar y el
euro eso
beneficiaría digamos a destinos en
europa frente a eeuu en este momento
mira
esa humanidad que en un momento muy
lejana y que se mantuvo y que se aplicó
la moneda europea y en algunos países
por ejemplo en chile ya ha pasado esa
barrera y seguirá ajustando ya la
diferencia es muy pequeña por lo tanto
eso ha abierto quizás la posibilidad de
poder mirar a europa como un lugar
cierto donde poder establecer esa visión
de turismo pero sin olvidar que europa
también está sufriendo un tema de
inflación y por lo tanto los precios de
europa también están subiendo al alza ya
eso sí con una característica que
importante mucho más controlada que lo
que estamos viviendo en latinoamérica y
eeuu como dices tú por lo tanto hoy día
esta paridad podría ya abrir un poquito
el mercado europeo y ver los ojos más
accesibles porque esa era la gran
diferencia de la gran problema entre
familias que se tenían momento en el
tema de
el mayor valor pero una diferencia sería
que estamos viviendo la inflación de una
mosca en varios continentes pero la
inflación en europa está poco más
controlada que es lo que tenemos
nosotros aquí en latinoamérica y en
estados unidos fundamentalmente así es
arturo pues muchísimas gracias por estar
con nosotros en directo américa de
france 24 pues resolviendo un poco las
dudas que podemos tener los viajeros en
esta época del año a no sé si quiere
cumplir rápido con algo y bueno se me
quedan muchas preguntas en el aire pero
pues definitivamente es
tomar decisiones es muy difícil en este
momento donde tenemos un dólar
fortalecido en muchos sitios y una
inflación también muy alta en muchos
sitios voy a mirar a ver qué decisión
tomó yo personal vamos a ver con qué
decisión va a tomar daniela arturo un
abrazo gracias y buen día estábamos
conversando con arturo farías a que
demente académico investigador de la
facultad de administración y economía de
la universidad tecnológica metropolitana
de chile